so you are a white privileged male who
has hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster i'm konstantine
kissin and this is the show for you if
you want honest conversations with
fascinating people our brilliant and
returning guest today is a
singer-songwriter actor and one of our
favorite human beings in the world
Lawrence Fox welcome back to
trigonometry hi guys thanks for back and
explain before we start we are of course
immediately in the post lockdown
situation we've all got crazy hair cuts
Frances has lost weight which was never
gonna happen otherwise it's true and the
world's about to explode how you been
well yeah just in anticipation of the
apocalypse which seems to be heading our
way
soon and would you predict the last time
you were on the show I mean I say that
with a smile I don't know what I know
we're always do well in an apocalypse
don't we yeah we do
well I don't know why I said we do and
to quote Batman
some people just want to watch the world
burn and that is of course the three of
us not actually because the last time
you were then being serious you know you
said you see a fight coming and here it
is yeah it's not good is it
I feel like it was already possibly too
late by then in a way because you could
see that people lost their good faith
and they didn't want to talk anymore and
that they're you know as you go into his
arguments and people are just looking to
to find that the tiny disagreement that
they can turn into a little hand grenade
that they can then turn in tip from a
skirmish into a war and you know I think
we're probably we're getting there feels
very very young it uneasy doesn't it if
I don't I'm not fine I don't feel
relaxed I mean no one's gonna feel
relaxed and we're in the middle of a
lockdown but the lockdown and the
combination of their you know that's
tension this building is and Lawrence
you have been there I say on a little
bit of a journey
I mean euphemistically how are you and
how have you found it I'm all right now
it was pretty surprising actually before
but then I suppose someone level I was
already
poking the elephant wasn't I well give
us a bit of the chronology Lawrence
because when we interviewed you I
believe that I think it's accurate to
say that was the first four long-form
interview that you've done talking about
the whole culture war stuff and your
thoughts on it and from there you go you
do a bunch of other podcasts you and
eventually you end up on question time
one which is where I think the journey
yes described it really starts and we
might even include a little clip of that
at the top of this so just take us from
there what what happens so I go into the
I would did radio 5 live the day before
with the eternally moderate and yes
minilily Brown was on before she's
always balanced and you know and I was
because I was singing as well I was I
could hear her being interviewed and I
was just going home really which is what
I think often when I stare at the TV and
so I sort of vaguely mentioned it in my
interview with me how and then the next
day in the aisle and then I went to
Liverpool on the train and got question
time and they've sort of everyone's
there with their sort of assistants and
you know people with little briefcases
and lawyers things and following around
there they're contestants and briefing
them and stuff like that and then I sort
it one look at the drinks table of
thought now and when do that because
they lay out a load of booze I think
they probably want to kind of get people
going yes he did George best basically
doodles best and or in Oliver Reed and
then yeah I mean I just I just said what
I thought which I would have said it at
a TV if I was staring at the TV watching
it you know to me notes I would have
said exactly the same thing and then you
forget that millions of people are
watching it because you just sort of
responding how you'd respond and then I
went back to the hotel and Shappy wasn't
massively keen on a chat and a catch-up
post question time momen and then we
were sitting in I thought us all fine
and then I went to my bedroom
you mean Shami Chakrabarti okay well
you're now racist because you
mispronounced one word
one letter in her name it's true and yes
if she wasn't me up for a chat and I
went to my room and I said once a brief
look at Twitter and I thought I got 75
thousand Twitter followers and then I
woke up next morning and I'd like
hundred and something else and it was
all kind of fairly good-natured at the
beginning I didn't feel too like I was
being jumped on and then sometime the
next afternoon he started getting really
quite nasty
and I started going oh I might have to
have Anna have an opinion about some
stuff and then it slowly descended into
sort of a major pile on and I sort of
you know they're bad faith pylons that
Twitter are famous for they just you
know you want to be people want to
misrepresent you in the media will do it
the same so I then got shocked so they
went to see my doctor because I was
having massive panic attacks and she
gave me some pills which are great by
the way I've just come off them and and
I saw a little passerby over give it a
week and then it didn't and it carried
on going at code ongoing and it
culminated in equity the actors Union
which I'd missed actually by the by of
them saying you know I'm a disgrace and
denounce and I thought well you know
this is that's what unions do don't they
when you used to watch the cheap strikes
and stuff he'd always have Bob Crowe
going you know using really the emotive
language and you think cool whatever but
then someone said to me that's a big
deal actually because that's your actors
union those are the that's you don't
want that at the top of when someone
good right now be the quadrant of Bob
crowd announcing his own transport stuff
or whatever Union he was in up Lawrence
was the worst train driver we've got
[Laughter]
always wanted to find that prick yeah so
yeah so then I am as I I was really
shocked lots of you know my family would
didn't know what to do
really it was really affecting life I
mean people came after my family came
after my loved ones
and I thought I have see so impractical
can I just touch on something what do
you mean came after Lawrence they
attacked you know they attacked they
tried to draw divisions between my
family members you know people would the
media would comment on various parts of
my you know relationships are talking
within the family that they just weren't
informed about so it's and I then got
some calls from my family saying that
what are we can do about this because
this is really upsetting for everybody
and I'm like yeah no I got it I'm right
there and so it just got worse and worse
and worse I threatened to sue equity for
defamation because I think at the end of
the day you know what they said to me
was was unfair I didn't think I was
really I mean I admit you know it's a
fairly controversial thing to say that
mega Markel as an actress may have an
ego that made you know and want to be
center of attention which is sort of
what I was saying I didn't really have
any interest in the color of her skin or
anyone else's skin really because I just
it's not really I know this is really
bad to say that isn't it yeah it's
horrific I mean the thing I actually
said at the time is and this is a purely
a reflection of my ignorance about Megan
Markel I'm not I don't watch that me
movies what's with her in them I didn't
realize that she was quote unquote black
like people with super well apparently
okay right I didn't know I still don't
know right I just want to say I'm a
massive fan of you making any woman of
color really but but I'm very liberal
anyway let's carry on very progressive
especially down below the waist but this
is the point is like I didn't know that
she was she was black I don't think
people did today I think there was there
been rumblings in the press of the fact
that she was being treated different but
I mean I don't really read the press so
all I'd the last time I'd seen Megan
Markel was at her wedding and that
looked like a pretty nice shindig to me
you know they were interviewing people
outside and we were watched it as a
family and it was raw wedding time we
loved it
this is brilliant she's great I'd not
read anything negative about it so I was
like come on guys it's not about racism
this is about an actress who is not
properly thought through what giving you
a life in service to the crown is all
about well that's part of it I think the
other part of it is what happened is she
started and then encouraged Harry to
start lecturing public about how they
should behave and you made that point on
question time about actors you know
actors who preach about you know at the
time it was extinction rebellion that
was the big thing and then top in their
private jet and go to the Bahamas for a
three-week beach holiday right
and that's kind of what what the Royals
those two Royals were doing and I think
a lot of the public and as reflected in
some of the press were pissed off about
that as and as you said that's not
really about race is it that's no I
don't people don't like being lectured
to anyway do they and also when you're
finding things to divide people it's it
stops conversations so you know if you
subjective eyes something like race
which you've got to do because you've
someone says you did the only lived
experience you have in life is your own
that's it there is no other lived
experience but your own and you know you
can sort of see into the windows of
other people's that you know really well
well but so you one wasn't denying
subjective feelings of racism but this
sort of overwhelming we are the really
rate really racist and I'm like well you
know we'll it will be so racist then why
are people crossing the Mediterranean on
rubber dinghies to get to these horrible
bigoted shores of ours I mean Francis
and I both have met rail racer so
there's not like they don't exist and I
know you know you've met some real
racists as well I mean they do exist the
question is is one stupid racist reflect
reflective of society that's that's
really the question that you were
addressing and it's um it becomes an
agenda then slightly it feels to me so
if you're going to talk about systemic
racism then at some point I'm gonna need
some facts
hmmm that's I'm just gonna need it
because I can't take your word for it if
that's not my lived experience now I'm
you know qualify that by saying of them
I haven't had the lived experience of
her you know I was speaking to a friend
the other day said you've not been
called a [ __ ] and being told to go home
I mean the Home Secretary said it on TV
but apparently I read yesterday that
that's gaslighting other ethnic
minorities and you're like if the Home
Secretary who's Brown has a view and
says I was called the [ __ ] in the
schoolyard and then you're going she's
now the Home Secretary that would point
towards the fact that possibly this
country is quite progressive in terms of
how we handle race but so essentially
race is now an opinion rather than a
color of your skin it seems because when
you were talking about it did you feel
that you sort of stamp stumbled into a
land mine issue or onto a land mine
issue without being fully aware of what
would it happen yeah no I no idea I
thought was fairly sensible comment I
mean I didn't look at it for a long time
and then I looked at it much later on
and I thought yeah now I do believe that
I stand by that there's nothing I mean I
maybe shouldn't have banged my head on
the desk because that was just slightly
disrespectful but it was frustrating and
you you're being walked into an argument
that if the minute you accept the
argument exists you're you've lost the
argument because I didn't accept the
terms of the argument that she was
laying down so therefore it wasn't
really it wasn't really an argument it
was a lecture and you know nothing
bristles someone them being lectured to
we don't want to lecture to each other
when we talk to each other absolutely
and then there was obviously the Sikh
comment which is where actually it's
really really went to the next level
when it all became very very vitriolic
would you like to tell us about what
happened there well the Sikh comment was
in a in a podcast and you know also
listen the thing about podcast is that
their opportunities get along form
discussions their opportunities to talk
you don't turn up with the finished
article of your ideas do you know until
I go right this is my position on x y&z
you talk to learn to understand to gain
more insight and knowledge so I did
think when I saw 1970
I thought it felt slightly tokenistic
that there was just one Sikh soldier I
thought you could have a platoon in the
back of that truck and you know and so
it's a fairly innocuous statement
I mean helpful possibly not what some
men DS trying to do something really
good and point out yeah absolutely
but again it was about faith argument
it's like you know what I meant you know
and but this is what I said to you at
the time man is like I knew exactly what
you meant and the funny thing about that
is obviously people won't know this but
you were the one that recommended I
watched 1917 before that you actually
gave me a DVD of it there's a watch and
you said this is a great movie yeah
there's gonna go watch it and I did but
the with the thing with that comment was
I think everybody knew exactly what you
meant and including many Sikhs who came
out and supported you but but you can't
give an inch to these people you if you
allow them even any opportunity to
misinterpret something you say they will
go for you I think that's right and
that's fine because people in charge
themselves know their own agency and
that's cool where it stops being find is
the media so I would remember David
Walliams then charming dude that hears
with possibly no dark past national
television awards is talking about how
empty my diary was yeah it was slightly
hissed in a way he was food it wasn't
appreciated and then he went on to make
a joke about Caroline Flack straight
after and then Caroline fat he's in a
slightly different position to me
emotionally for whatever reason we're
two separate individuals went on to take
her own life
and I would say that that that the the
media and herself and all everything but
are culpable in some aspect of that and
including David Williams and Dave
Williams his approach was just a turn of
Twitter for seven days and then get back
to posting pictures of his dog so yeah I
think that it's important that we were
able to just freely express ourselves in
good faith and and that seek
comment was you know people knew people
knew what I was saying that you know I
had to go on this I went on Good Morning
Britain I think ultimately what I really
should have done was just shut all the
doors to everything and and hunker down
but because of this thing about the fact
that they won't let you go they're like
dogs wild dogs coming after you you have
to fight back you didn't which I did
fight that for a while but then I looked
at the seat coming over I thought you
know what that I could I could miss
interact with that and in order to
reduce flames and energy and heat and
anger because that's what you want to do
in life that's what I want to do in life
while still maintaining the right to
freedom of speech I thought I will just
say look but I think everyone who died
in war and everyone served in war is a
really bad thing and you know it just
re-energizes them to come so you can't
really once you've been tarred and
feathered all you're doing is getting
more tar and more feathers every time
you open your mouth so you know like
that's why Trump is so successful
because he just doesn't care it's like
the man is Teflon isn't he you say
anything to him and he just and he's
just like he doesn't care to the point
of comedy almost and Lawrence I was
going to ask as well is with social
media do you think that what it makes
social meet what social media does is it
makes it very very easy to demonize
someone because sitting opposite from
you I get the fully rounded human being
but on Twitter you just get the avatar
with a little picture therefore it makes
it so much easier to create in my mind
who you are mmm absolutely it's the
Twitter serve is a is a horrible place
you know I turn it off once in a while I
certainly turned it off I had to turn it
off at one point so I was going geez I'm
never gonna get another job and you know
but it still happens that the problem is
once you stifle a really little debate
like about nuance if you take something
new on the scene and someone takes a
very strong position on it very nuanced
issue then when you get to the big
issues you're [ __ ] because you know
and so it's it's in bad faith this thing
and I know I keep saying it but I'm done
with that conversation so it and that's
really sad and that's why we're heading
towards where we're heading probably
this well last weekend
depending you know is that people are
just putting down words and they're
picking up aggression and anger and
violence and you know and where's that
going to lead us and the point you made
about the media I think is very powerful
right now but actually you reminded me
when you talked about the David Walliams
joke that joke llantas comedians we can
you know when a joke works or not
that joke died yeah well he died on its
ass but here's my point I only found out
about what happened and read about it
and watched it because I saw a newspaper
article which said David Walliams
brilliantly destroys Laura or something
along those lines they they just lied
they just [ __ ] lied they took
something to happen and they
misrepresented it as the opposite yeah
how how does that how does it happen
David Walliams largely succeed largely
peaceful character assassination of
Lawrence Fox and you know it's really
bad I'm alright cuz I have a really good
support network but you do have to think
about the people that aren't alright and
you do have to think about that you know
what are the likelihood of people
appearing in reality TV shows ending up
with severe mental health problems you
know and how much of this is Twitter's
responsibility and and you know someone
said to me recently they said I was like
I've gotta go after Sarah I can't cope
there and they said the best minds in
you know in the Silicon Valley are
working on ways of keeping you on
Twitter the smartest cleverest people
are trying to keep you on there and it's
and you go yeah weird this is a this is
bad this is really really painful so I
think the only constant I can find in
the whole thing it's not all the media
either it's the it's the outrage media
that have just gone they've got dealt
their hand and the hand is I the ten of
truth the jack of honesty and the six of
whatever and and they just throw it down
and they go right what do I want to do
here and I suppose they've always done
it but it's probably got more power now
it's got more reach you've got more
shares everything I say for example is
digitally permanently there it isn't
like people you send your mozi isn't
yesterday's tomorrow chip paper even
it's there for you to see but I've been
oh I would rather speak a lot and get a
few things wrong than not speaking
ever hello and welcome to my hangout its
borrowdale légende now we've got a new
sponsor for you this week it's config
our IT configure IT basically and date
or an IT company and they can do a whole
load of things for you allow me to
explain if your business wants of
migrate workload to the cloud and let's
be fair drink Ovid who wouldn't want to
be in a cloud mate if you want to
reinforce your network security but do
not have the expertise if you need to
deploy a network solution whether it's
on your on-premises cloud or Wi-Fi
infrastructure I don't know any of those
words make if you want to it grade your
networker state or improve its
monitoring if you need to link your
staff customers and workload wherever
they are then contact config our IT to
configure it document it and support it
so if you want to discuss your IT
networking and security requirements go
to config our IT and their website is
config - R - IT dot dot uk' these people
really know what they're doing with IT
unlike me I've just spoken a lot of
words I've got no idea what any of this
means
and I remember on our first interview
when you started saying you know your
opinions some of which I really agreed
with in my in my head because I know a
little bit about acting I've got friends
who are actors I'm thinking he's [ __ ]
nuts and expect because acting as we all
know is the most liberal in inverted
commas industry there is and by that I
mean it's famously illiberal if you
disagree with any of what they say or
think how have you found that your
bookings have gone down have they been
reduced and all the rest of it well we
hit the lock down dimly but I did get
the my favorite ever text message saying
it's something along the lines of acting
what are you doing acting
is the most liberal compassionate
business in the [ __ ] world you'll
never work again and I'm like you I mean
what how do I deal with this as a text
message I think that there are what's so
interesting about acting that I've
noticed now because I've started to look
at it is I don't look at the ones that
do there I am responsible I don't look
at those ones I look for who's not on
those Vaness and I've started to see and
you start to notice who's not in those
videos and then you start to look who
what's up parts they play and stuff like
that and you start skill oh okay so they
really said there is something going on
there is a culture or also within show
business
but you know we are we are I think a lot
of films now you were often with your
leading males especially they're there
they're much less sort of I don't know
testosterone II than they would have
been back in the day they're much more
available and vulnerable than then your
classic leading man would have been and
hence you know the films have a slightly
different quality to them you know
there's there's less shootouts in you
tend to get one or two films a year
where you'll get a lot of proper meted
out kind of western-style
violence or whatever and then the rest
will be sort of complex dramas that you
know you'll that it's like watching your
best friend's so it's I don't I'm I want
to be transported when I watch films so
I've started watching all the films
again now I mean older films for me like
you know Good Will Hunting or something
like that
there are they're not also problematic I
mean watch mrs. Doubtfire the other day
and I was triggered oh man may you watch
anything from like ten years ago and
you're going what they made this what
and it's like ten years ago but you know
as you were talking there it it reminded
me of something because I to my
grandparents and parents about life in
the Soviet Union and the stuff you're
talking about where you have to look for
who's not signing up to a cause is
exactly what we had like I get messages
now from people going oh you know by the
way this other comedian he's one of us
and I'm going like what do you mean one
of us like why do we have to speak in
hushed tones and private messages about
us like this
there's something seriously [ __ ] up
here if if people like us have to you
know gather and private and you know you
keep the keep our voices down which is
what's happening but what so good is now
we're living in the world where people
have the most information they've ever
had yeah so that's a good thing when
people use it well and it's a really bad
thing when people use it badly but but
ultimately you know if it will go wrong
we can just go and live in chance I love
the fact that they've given it the name
of a really posh woman in from Clapham
darling yeah I'm not sure we're gonna
get visas for that name do you not think
there were welcome in no idea we might
have the wrong skin color man are we not
the we know the we're just different
size the same coin this is the whole
point isn't you've got you it throughout
history there's been too crazy doomsday
cultist lunatics and they have to be
countered with you know fairly rational
reasoned sensible thought but we've it's
exploding now because I think people
forget as well a friend of mine said to
me the other day he went I didn't
realize how thick some younger students
were because he said they just didn't
they've not been taught this stuff so I
was taught at school about the Soviet
Union and I was taught about Nazi
Germany and we studied it and crystal
meth and all this stuff not to some
great standard I'm not the smartest man
in the world but I know about it and I
know the motives behind it and I you can
see the trajectory of how these things
play out I don't think these guys get
taught it I think they're far too busy
being taught that you know to fail his
first attempt at learning or something
you know is it's sort of there's a book
sort of I don't know you'd see the
blacks blacks wait
none of the arguments have any weight so
I'm yet to meet someone I mean what's
that dude on David Pakman he's got some
fairly decent left-wing arguments but
under my mate Paul has got some good
laughing I ruins but I and I appreciate
those but you know discreet she
screeched she [ __ ] you [ __ ] you stuff is
like well where do I go without me you
know you screaming at me all you want at
the end of the day where does it end
either I turn you off or you know I
can't
you obviously I just do nowadays I don't
block them I just meet them and I just
have this wake up and with a warm
feeling of someone going into the air
forever and how do we get out of this
situation because it just feels and I
don't think it's unfair and saying this
you know you just feels like it's
getting worse all the time how do we get
out I don't think miss get out didn't we
all gonna get out thanks Nate I'm sorry
I just I've got a feeling that there's a
cycle of life and after a long period of
peace people want to fight and it feels
so aggressive and so it doesn't feel
like there is a conversation to be had
and it also feels like people are taking
sides as well like you know corporations
are taking science individuals are
taking science here and they'll wake up
who's gonna win and go I'll be on that
side and ultimately you know it does it
feels like those with those that are
willing to fight in the cruelest and
nastiest way probably gonna win but
ultimately the best reaction the best
generals in response to the ones that
are much more cold and much more measure
to you know and they just go this is how
I will defeat you in the long run but
I've got a feeling it will get bad I
don't feel it's it doesn't seem like
it's getting any less bad does it you
know it's I feel very depressed about it
and I feel sad for my kids you know and
you know I'd said I said the other day
about this taking the knee thing I was
like I just totally stand by anyone's
right and desire to take the knee I'm
just not gonna do it because and I was
walking around the park with that dude
Andrew because he started slacking me
off on Twitter and he lives in near
where I live and I was like why don't we
just get together for a chat and he is a
left-wing trans person yeah yeah yeah
he's got a lot of intersections going on
and he was striking me off and I was
like hey man nice to meet you and I
think that disarms people sometimes and
I said then listen don't you don't hate
me
we can talk why don't we go for a walk
you've got a dog I've got a dog so we go
for a walk he explains to me that um you
know why taking me is a good idea nice
it him okay I take that on board but you
have to understand that in a sort of
way up from sort of feudal culture
through the MIDI the Middle Ages up to
today where you're taking me to get
knighted by the Queen as partly its
ingrained in every sort of person in
English culture that taking any has
totally different significance than it
does to what it does for you know people
in America perhaps or people somewhere
else so there is an argument there for
someone to defend the right to say well
I say it's an act of subservience rather
than an act of solidarity it's it's
that's okay in my view anyway Amory then
says to me so good to talk to you this
is in public he's getting signal to talk
to you I recommend you read this book so
I go great I'll get that book and I'll
read it I recommend you read Doug's
Moe's madness of crowds and he won't
know I'm not going to read that
transphobes stuff and having read
Douglas Murray and there's nothing
transphobic right man at all
in fact his chapter on trans issues in
the in Amanda's crowds is so sensitively
handled that I thought wow that's
incredibly withheld for you know someone
who can be quite pointed like Douglas
and and and I just thought that's there
we have it the difference between you
and me Andrew is I'll read your book but
you won't read mine and therefore you
know when it comes to a fight which no
one wants you're fighting with one hand
tied behind your back if you come from a
place of reason because they don't care
what the rules are I think it's quite
deliberate I think it's the way that
their ideology is designed it's designed
in such a way that it's closed off to
external information because if you if
you argue as they do that words of
violence that by saying that you don't
think that you know if you just say that
you're a woman right now you like that
you've become a woman for example right
that is erasing the identity of somebody
or that is violence against them and if
that's the case well if I thought that
reading the book is the equivalent of
punching me in the face maybe I wouldn't
want to read that book either so if you
think in that way it all internally
within that system makes sense and
that's how the system is designed it's
designed to
new information from coming in yeah well
is its it is what it's that religion is
a religion it's an impenetrable very
dangerous religion and you know and they
keep coming up with these the the
problem is they can't live up to their
with their own edicts so essentially
they the only way they can forgive is by
forgiving their own kind you know so
you'll have Trudeau taking a knee and
and no point will anyone point out the
enormous autocracy of the fact we had to
build his own penis whatever in socks in
his when he was blacked himself up first
uh and you're right that takes you
blacked your own knees up in your ripped
jeans like you really went to town on
this look you know and and I just think
it makes it sense and therefore it's
very difficult to live in a world so not
in my senses are Oh worries me Lawrence
I'm like how can these people constantly
come up with new edicts that they break
day after day after day it's rode
themselves endlessly into these problems
and constantly forgive each other but
everyone else is a heretic what's the
way out of that because the rational and
sensible people in this world are not
going to put up with that and you know
they were saying seventy percent of
Democrats in America were in support of
the National Guard going onto the 70% of
Americans sorry not Democrats were in
support of putting the National Guard
and the streets during the riots and I
mean I couldn't get 70 percent of people
to agree on anything so there is a
groundswell against these guys and then
you know you worry about what where that
groundswell manifests itself and you
know you go and try and pull down the
wrong statue with a few people that are
fiercely patriotic in you know in the
sense that they are patriotic and you're
gonna have a big rumble and who wants
that and why are the police not stopping
that and why are we not you know
why is that it shouldn't be happening it
offends people you don't want it don't
offend people Francis before you jump in
but just very quickly I should say we're
recording this on a Friday before
weekend who the [ __ ] knows what's going
to happen with anyway go for it
I think the problem is is that we I
think it comes to both sides isn't it in
that they're unaware at times of their
own of what will be the long-term
consequences of these actions so they
pulled down the Edward Colson statue now
there's perhaps a very strong argument
that we shouldn't have a statue of
somebody who made a large amount of
money from slavery
however by taking down the statue that
then creates a ripple effect where we
look at all other statues and go but
should we take this down should we take
that down
should we take down Cromwell statue
after the atrocities in Ireland and then
what you start to have is raising
people's history which will then really
rankle with the other side but people
don't seem to want to acknowledge that
it's crazy especially over the statue
thing because also is it as much there's
an argument for removing it it's not
even leaving in place right so it's
whatever happens the argument for
leaving in place is you know I take your
children to the statue and they go who's
that and you go this guy was a famous
slave trader and they're like what's
they brain you tell them yeah so it's
there's a great there's a solid argument
for that but there's also a solid
argument for removing it
but whatever the argument is it's needs
to be a democratic process because once
the mob takeover it's like hang on a
minute you'll you know that's not the
how we do these things I mean I don't
know the history of the statue so I
think they had been lobbying the council
to have it removed and whatever but yeah
they had a vote on it it was 54% of
people didn't want it removed well so
and maybe look if they had a vote now
I'm sure it would be removed and your
point about the democrat democratic
process is absolutely right it's
interesting that you mentioned that
there's an argument for keeping these
things up maybe with a plaque that
explains who this person was what they
did etc because I went to school and in
my school one of the alumni was Douglas
Haig who was the commander of the
British Armed Forces in World War one
right responsible for the over-the-top
tactics etc which would largely act
alone is acknowledged as being terrible
having led to the deaths of thousands of
young British men for no purpose
whatsoever and we were taught about this
at school we would walk past a statue
every single day and then we'd go to a
history class what they would tell us
this is what this guy did he was a
[ __ ]
right and we'd learn about it hmm what
do you want what work what do you armed
children with knowledge that's what you
want on them with you don't want to arm
them with opinions you know you can get
your kids are gonna pick up your own
opinions anyway I'm and they're gonna
pick up the opinions of the people that
teach them and all that sort of stuff
but your arm them with knowledge and you
give them the tools to understand and
I've I've got a horrible feeling that is
being this is been going on for years
this deliberate indoctrination and
removal of any form of ability to think
for yourself critically think and you're
just sat there you know I lots of
conversations with people where they're
like they'll just spewed things that
aren't true at me and I'll have to go
okay but this is the thing this is the
truth it's like having an argument with
someone who's screaming in your face and
you video it on your phone and you then
you show it back to them and they went I
wasn't angry with you okay where I don't
even know where we begin so yeah educate
educate educate kids are curious
creatures I kept that mainly I the
reason why I actually say this stuff is
because I have children I don't really
care so much for myself but I'm looking
and this game kind of it's this bad now
what's he gonna look like when they're
young adults how do I want them to get
into a scrap so sort of vainly and
stupidly I thought well maybe is worth
loving my 5x into this conversation but
oh boy have they tried to make me pay
for it
it's been painful and Lawrence do you
regret getting involved in this
conversation
no no truth the truth man you've got to
stick to the truth truth is what what
matters truth the information allowing
people to work out what to think
argue the [ __ ] out of it fight with each
other disagree don't fight physically
but really you know allow I allow it to
happen allow these conversation to
happen if they don't happen other things
happen and that's what happens profound
sight of the day it's not shy at all
because this is you know this is why we
started the show we started the show two
years ago and on a much smaller scale
but we've gone through exactly the same
thing with our careers but I got to be
honest to you and I've said this to
people in private but I said to you now
I think we're failing I don't I don't
think we're succeeding what do you mean
I'm
that the way the world is going I don't
think us talking about it is gonna stop
it
so what sells everything I don't know
that's a Russian and you coming out
again yeah that's a Chekhov joke for
anybody anyway well done mate that's the
first time Francis has elevated himself
above the level of wank jokes in there
in about three months we'll be back to
wang chos guys don't worry about it I
know my core audience so what I want to
have an answer I want to go this is what
we do and then this is what we're doing
then this is what we do but all I can
see now as I look into the future is how
do you stop the violence in the short
term okay well you prevent the
protestors from different sides from
getting together that's what you do
right what do you do after that what's
the next step it's that way it's that
one up there I'm afraid it's the only
answer whether you believe in it or not
it's the only answer because what are we
going to come out of this with we're
certainly not going to come out of the
situation that we've just been through
with the great faith in scientists it's
like don't worry I'm a scientist let me
like [ __ ] you know it's there scientists
of the new estate agents now son it's
like so people need meaning right we've
spent a long time looking for science we
have to turn around and look to the to
the values of the real values that
society was built on and those are
judeo-christian values and that's the
other look up there and look at what was
said by him and what was said by the
people that followed him that's what I
reckon that's my view and that's not
coming from a person who's like
profoundly religious I'm just going
there is a manual they wrote a book
about this before you know and and try
and bring some of those those values
back you know it's very complex things
within the Bible that are really tricky
to get your head around and they can
educate and you know all you can do is
educate your kids educate the people
around you like I've sort of took took a
bit of a break off Twitter and I've
started using a family whatsapp group
instead so that I want to share this
information because you know you're not
going to get back but you can still
disagree you know and just gather with
all sorts of people and always offer
them your good faith that see anything I
can think because you know the it's
gonna be abused
regardless by a small minority but I
think they are a small minority I don't
lean people are stupid is their media
think they are and I don't think people
are as sheepy as their media in the
Twitter thing there and I think people
think that touches real-world me
absolutely isn't you know think about
will people that don't tweet man I got a
stack of letters a stack huge stack of
letters just from people saying thank
you so much for saying that you know and
it's like 33 cosgrove reports of a man
yeah so I think there's a very look the
the more peaceful side of the argument
is quiet it doesn't want to get into
trouble
I'm in trouble I mean I'm not I mean I
am but I'm no ultimately I'm not because
no I'm not I know that I'm not trying to
operate my heart in a negative and
malicious way a malevolent leg to cause
other people harm I'm trying to go this
not calls each other harm and in spite
of all of the [ __ ] that has being
chucked at me I'm grateful for that [ __ ]
actually cuz it makes you stronger
and you know you I just don't feel you
can do that alone as I said before I'm
just like when I felt like help me
please get me out of this I don't go
like an oak or I call a friend or
whatever but I'm not like oh maybe I'll
read this you know it's like no it's
it's within you you know the world is
within you your world is the world so
you know you better off being yourself
than being anyone else as Oscar Wilde
said isn't it and do you think there are
a lot of there are some people who use
what is happening very cynically as a
way to promote their career yeah you
know them have you have your opinion it
doesn't bother me just allow me mine I
know that is where we're [ __ ]
hmm is the fact that we're fighting over
the right to have an opinion
and that there by that time like I said
in about that faith argument its you've
already lost mmm
you know if you're not meeting someone
in going ivan opinion the other opinion
you know the i could see the way that
Amory was looking at me he'd made up his
mind about me and I'm never gonna change
his mind about me but it will never stop
me inviting him to go for a walk and
that's the best you can do a new hope
that worked that in some recess of my
brain stuff that he says he said
something really interesting to me about
racism right which stuck with me and
I've kept it he said it's like mosquito
bites being subjected to racist attacks
like one is not too bad it's a bit
annoying bases get hundreds of them your
life becomes unbearable hmm and that
really stuck with me and I thought
that's a really brilliant way of
explaining it and I've taken that away
and I've thought yeah we should be more
we should be gentler and and more
understanding and more aware of these
issues because they do cause people
great hate but on when I returned with
yeah well later on round our little walk
around the park and I spoke about their
you know what kneeling potentially would
mean to you know English they are
[Music]
there's no other way
what do you indeed I build a heart full
of hatred for these people unlike no
[ __ ] off I love you it's fine do what
you want do your worst as well and I'll
always remember this quote we were
talking to countdown killer the guy who
made the pug video and he said something
that always stuck with me said we don't
really believe in forgiveness anymore do
you know that's the case well they don't
certainly know okay there is no
forgiveness in that religion isn't there
because it's so immediate and the
inspections are so constant that it's
like Isis someone was saying to me that
it within Isis as an organization they
you know if you're not the most hardcore
terrorists then you'll kill the slightly
less hardcore one you know so it's a
competition it's a race to the top of
extremism and you know so that they
incentivize you becoming more and more
crazy and insane and you know they're
cancelling their own now so hopefully
they'll you know go and all go off to
chars summer in chance ring this year do
you know how transformational that would
be for so many people to go and actually
see their little utopia play out in all
its horror and dirty glory well maybe
that's why he's lead with that maybe
that's why the Orangemen bad is his
leaving not saying anything about it
just she wants them all to form one big
chairs and just leave him in there for
you know weeks they'll learn the
Americas in a place where what would
happen if he ordered his generals to go
into and break up chance that's that's
where Americas are so that we think with
febrile yeah you know imagine things
that please go and protect that statue
in that piece there no I'm just gonna
stop the conversation do you know how
mental the what just happened is yeah
there's like a little independent
republic now that is called itself
chairs that has walled itself off from
everyone where people now want to live
independently and in in downtown Seattle
and everyone thought okay it's just
funny now you can't not laugh or you
can't take this stuff seriously and it's
obviously a stupid little game because
the moment the power companies turn off
the electricity and the city stops taken
away the trash and the vegan sausages
run out the vegan side I was gonna talk
about something happen but I can't even
be bothered like it's it's just a joke
it's it's a game that they play and they
pretend that it's real but it's not and
I don't know what to do about it because
it's just how can you not laugh at it
anymore they're like they're like body
both kids all right
no I'm living here this is my castle
y'all not coming into my house it was my
casa was an ice castle with nice
princesses and princes who were really
nice to each other
is that okay man cool
see you in George house Thank You HS
brilliant I mean I constant I disagree
with this I think a lot of the reason
why we've ramped up the insanity is
lockdown yeah no I think yeah I think
you're right and then part of me thinks
EPS that would I mean the really cynical
horrible part of my brain thinks oh
that's all part of the idea all part the
plan was to to was to put people into
that position and then wind them up and
see what happened you know because I
mean at the end of the day well how many
I mean that lots of people are dieting
it's a [ __ ] horrific tragedy and it's
really bad for old people but it's the
reaction proportionate to the danger so
no certainly not the reaction was
certainly proportionate to what Niall
Ferguson said the danger was but in with
hindsight are we going to look back and
say the reaction was proportionate to
this danger I think possibly not
his penis didn't yeah that's true that's
I still can't hate him you got you got a
respect a guy way above his average
she's got the opportunities went for it
how romantic is that honey of risk death
to be hit death my career and the future
of the country just to be here that's
how much I love you baby
it's them both getting into their little
scientific suits yeah well why did we
buy it it's so English that isn't it as
well like we you sort of have a right do
you think our good old English spirit
will get out of this in some way and
then it all ends up [ __ ]
no problem and then like two months
later everyone's like I'll tell you why
I disagree with the two of you about the
lockdown being the critical issue here
because I I just see this we you said it
you said it here seven months ago before
there was any lockdown before we had
covered 19 this was always going to be
the final destination hmm and it's the
product of 30 or 40 years of the long
march of the institution's and doctrine
18 young people into thinking or not
thinking and feeling everything if I
feel this is true then it's true and you
see this playing out now maybe it
accelerated the process but I don't I
don't think it's I don't think it's to
lock down what did it I think it's the
fact that for 40 years they've been
making this happen and you know we live
in the you know ultimately we live in
the freest most democratic situation in
the history of mankind and you know if
you're still moaning about things then
you know on your iPhone you know my kids
can't even believe that I didn't have an
iPhone when I was a kid they just didn't
understand it really
yeah they disliked Oh rubbish how did
you get in touch with people what
happened when your dad went away at work
I said I never spoke to me went away for
three months and then he came back he
was too expensive to call my landline to
you know wherever he was filming and so
they just don't understand it so there
is an element of being a bit spoilt I
think and I don't like the argument that
and we're not doing enough to
try and reduce inequality because what
none of these conversations seem to be
about reducing inequality at all they
seem to be about maximizing it and
maximizing division and all of the
things I mean I've said it from the
beginning
I think the woky bunch are exactly what
they accuse you of to the very core and
it starts off with racism you know well
they're racist though I've always said
the the new racist yeah
it's so easy to you know throw it all at
somebody else and it's so sad yeah I
mean I fit under I wish I could go like
there's an answer but I know there isn't
I mean you know that people probably try
and cancel me again because I would have
said something stupid well [ __ ] off
sorry you know you guys have put this
together
in in that way and you know people
disagree but just disagree don't just go
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that
doesn't work just go this is why I
disagree with you engage the people do
it in good faith and we will we will
move on but we've done it man like we've
invited people who are critical of us
onto the show and do they come no no
they say we don't want to come on your
show you where I'm gonna be physically
attacked by your violent whatever was
followed no followers he was saying to
me he's like all of your followers are
like white supremacists all right okay
all of them are yeah yeah yeah our fans
don't attack people they don't go after
people and they don't do any of that we
just get people on to talk and we had
Lord of Donis on the show the architect
of the remain the remain second
referendum all of that [ __ ] people down
voted the video some of them some people
operated the video and appreciated that
we had a conversation that was it mmm
that was it
yeah like he lorded onus is like Lord
Voldemort said to the pro brexit crowd
we had him on the show we had a great
respectful conversation we agreed with
some of the things think she said we
disagreed with other stuff we've had
socialists on the show we've had people
up from all over the political spectrum
and that's why the cynical part of my
brain goes is just an excuse
they just don't want to have the
conversation though because they'd lose
the conversation it's like you know if
you ever try and engage people like that
you just stay quiet and wait for them to
time 7:00 or not you know that's that's
what happens anyone who acts in bad
faith you just go tell me why sorry and
then they'll expert they'll say
something really compassionate start off
with something very compassionate like
you need we just need to really support
each other I just don't believe we
support each other enough and I might in
what way do I agree with you what what
do you think we should do to support
each other he's don't know I did because
it's the only thing you can be in
control of is yourself and they don't
want to be in control of themselves do
they they want to be control you and me
and I'm like no no of that thanks chaps
[Music]
and we've come to the end of the
interview it's been absolutely brilliant
Lawrence but we always ask one question
at the end that is what is the one thing
we're still not talking about that we
ought to be talking about as a society
the kids education mmm how to educate
your children you know don't leave your
children to be educated by someone else
educating yourselves as much as possible
surround your children without surround
them with diverse opinions and diverse
you know not that diverse colors and all
of this stuff cut out sounds super
happen I think but it's not I didn't
want to have to point out that diversity
includes different colored skin of
course it does yeah make sure your kids
here equipped to deal with the world
because they're the ones that gonna have
to deal with what comes next
mm-hm that's a very good point Lawrence
thank you for coming back thank you it
is good to have you back we're all
trying to do the same thing man
and it's important that that you know I
just say I've seen your journey and I
think a lot a lot of people a lot of
people respect you tremendously for
speaking on these issues
I respect you tremendously for speaking
ization we really appreciate you coming
back I'm really grateful for you and me
thank you and well done doing what
you're doing because that's part of the
answer - all right well make sure you go
and check out Lawrence's all of his work
white lions is [ __ ] smashing it
white lines is my
yeah whiteline's is fashioning it let's
see whether my opinions get me into the
second series I gotta say being half
South American I do love white lines see
we've got back to that kind of basement
level of humor as I promise you what
happened the lockdown is served you well
made very good and I've just broken
social distancing on camera so we're
canceled officially thank you very much
for tuning in we'll see you in a couple
of days with another brilliant interview
and of course check out our live streams
if you haven't already that's where all
the top level banter happens thank you
very much and we'll see you very soon
take care guys thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word